[تصفيق]
احب اعرفكم
بيترز
قريتي هذه المراه في ان نقول نسميها العم
راء لانها خايفه يوصل انني قلت عن اسمها
وتعمل لي مشاكل هذه امراه تعرف كل شيء عن
اي شيء اذا حصل اي معرفه او معلومه على
على طول نروح لعندها وهي اللي تكلمنا ايش
اللي صاير الرويترز هذا موجود في كل قريه
في كل مجتمع اكيد كل واحد منكم يعرف
رويترز تبعه اللي احب اقول لكم ان الاعلام
التقليدي يعني مثلا الصحف التلفزيون
الاذاعات لم تعد ولم تكن هي مصدرنا الاول
او الرئيسي للمعلومات في اكثر من سبب طبعا
في عندنا سبب اللي هو ان احنا في ناس اقرب
لنا وفي واسرع ونثق فيهم اكثر فهي يعني
مساله الثقه او المصداقيه وايضا مساله
السرعه طيب تغير تعريف الاعلامي طبعا بسبب
تكنولوجيا الانترنت ومفهوم الاحتكار
للمعلومه انتهى لان تغير مفهوم الشخص
الاعلامي مادهو واحد صحفي ماسك جريده ولا
ورقه وقلم او اذاعي بمايكروفون اصبح كل
واحد منا ممكن ان يكون اعلامي او ينقل
معلومه بسبب تكنولوجيا الاتصال الجديده
وبالتالي مثلا شخص زي براء شيبان اللي
حطيت تويتر تبعه هنا تحيه له وين ما
هو استطاع بسبب الموقع التويتر تبعه انه
هو يثير جدل كبير حول الطيارات اللي بدون
طيار اكثر بكثير من اي اعلامي يكتب مقال
في صحيفه بيع كم 3 ال مثلا او برنامج في
التلفزيون طيب لما احنا نتكلم الان عن
الاعلام وتكنولوجيا الاتصال في حاجات اخرى
حصلت يعني خلال السنين
الماضيه حصل تطور تكنولوجي رهيب في
المعلومات اشياء اقوللكم او انقل لكم شويه
عن 2006 اثناء الانتخابات الامريكيه ايش
حصل في استوديو السي ان ان هذا مذيع اسمه
اندرسون كوبر ف انتقلوا معي
شويه i am who is live in grand park
let's see if can be him in now here we
go will thanks very much for being with
us uh how is this night for you oh this
is great you know we're at the eve of a
brand new day in america and it feels
good being here in chicago uh all this
technology i'm being beamed to you like
at star wars and stuff yeah it looks
like basically like exactly like in in
star trek when they would beam people
down that's what it looks like right
here yeah but yeah
ستار ورز تخيلوا تكنولوجيا الاتصال وصلت
الى اي مدى بامكاننا هذا في 2006 يعني
تخيلوا احنا 2014 ايش اللي ممكن نعمله في
مؤسسه زي السي ان ان استطاعت ان تست
تستضيف ضيف لها عن طريق الانتقال الضوئي
ثلاثي الابعاد ايش اللي حصل يعني ممكن بكل
سهوله زي السكايب كيف واحد يتواصل مع شخص
اخر بدل ما اصبح انه هو اشوفه صوره فقط
اصبح اشوفه على الثري دي او المجسم الثري
دي تخيلوا ابعاد هذا الشيء له علاقه
بالجريده كيف انك انت لو تجي تعرف ايش حصل
مثلا في البلد تسمع قاح بوم ولا اي حاجه
تن تسال بدل ما انك انت تروح تدور الجريده
اللي ح تصدر اليوم الثاني او التلفزيون
اللي كان يفتح صور من بلادي واغاني
والدنيا او الاذاعه الى حد معين لكن
الانترنت وتكنولوجيا الاتصال والروتر
تبعنا هو اللي يوصلنا المعلومه بشكل كبير
تكنولوجيا الاتصال ص وسط اليوم الى قدر زي
ماينتي ريبورت شفتم الفيلم توم كروز لما
كيف يتصرف بالحاجات الان يعني السمارت
فونز والتاب كل الادوات الاتصال هذه قد
سمحت لنا ان احنا نكبر نغير نرسل في لقطه
معينه في فيلم ماينور ريبورت اللي هو كان
في 2002 يعني في 2002 اليوم هذه الامور
صارت حقيقه ايش اللي حصل كان دخل في مركز
تجاري اللي يتذكر المقطع
والتقطت
العدسه بؤره العين وقالت له مستر مدري ايش
كيف عجبك الجاكيت في معنا دفعه جديده
مستعدين نبيع لك اياها فهذا التفصيل الكست
مايزي ششن انه هو للانسان انه اصبح واحد
ممكن انه يفتح موقع الكتروني ويقرا نفس
الخبر اللي يقراه شخص اخر بس يكون الخبر
ثاني الكوكيز او الكعكات اللي تدخل على كل
شويه يقوللك وانت تقول اوكي اوكي لما انت
توافق عليها انها تدخل في جها زك هي تتعرف
عليك شخصيتك ايش المواقع اللي تدخل لها
فانتبهوا يعني ايش ايش الحاجات اللي انت
تقراها في يعني ايش الامور اللي تثير
انتباهك فشيئا فشيئا ايش يصير الانترنت
بحجمه المهول يصير يتقمص يعني شخصيتنا او
يدخل الينا ويعرف احنا ايش نفكر تكنولوجيا
الاتصال اصبحت يعني كسرت كل حدود الاحتكار
للمعلومه والاعلاميين اللي عادهم يعني
حاسين انه هم هم اللي بيجيبوا لك كالخبر
ولا انه بيفصل خبر واحد زي يعني وكاله مش
حقول ايش من وكاله لكن انه هذا الخبر بس
يغيروا الاسماء والتواريخ ويرسل الخبر
للعالم هذا شيء انتهى طيب بتقولوا لي احنا
اليوم م لناش علاقه بهذا الموضوع تكلم عن
الانترنت ما فيش كهرباء احنا سمعنا عن هذا
الشيء الصباح صح لكن اقول لكم في 2010 كان
انتشار الانترنت في اليمن 2% فقط اليوم في
2014 10 اضعاف الان انتشار الانترنت في
اليمن 20 ضعف برضه بتقولوا لي حكايه
الكهرباء وبرد عليكم بقول لكم في ناس
خالتي في القريه معها انترنت ومعهاش
كهرباء ت شغل المولد عشان تتعامل
بالواتساب والفايبر
الفيسبوك يعني احنا عندنا ناس متخصصين
فيسبوك مفس بكين يعني هذول الناس مستحيل
انك انت ممكن يقولوا له ما فيش صرف صحي ما
فيش تعليم ما فيش في انترنت اوكي بيمشي
حياته فذلك ما تقولوا ليش لا اليمن فين
وانت تكلمين تكنولوجي الاتصال مش صحيح
احنا وصلنا لهذا هذا العصر هذه
التكنولوجيا غصبا عنا لانه نحتاج نتواصل
مع العالم الشخص اللي ما عندش الان مثلا
ايميل او ما عندش فيسبوك او تويتر او يعني
يبدا واتساب قبل سنه كانوا يقولوا لي حاجه
على الواتساب كنت اقول ايش هو الان مستحيه
انني قبل سنه ما كنتش عارفه ايش هو
الواتساب لكن الموضوع خلاص غصبا عنكم ح
تدخلوا تكنولوجيا الاتصال وتدخلوا عصر
التكنولوجيا طيب
عشان غصبا عنكم
يعني الله يرحمه ابراهيم مثنى صفحه
الفيسبوك حقه مفتوحه للان حد
زارها عمركم تخيلتم يا ريت رد علي يعني
خاصه تعليقاته اللاذعه يعني اللي يعرف
ابراهيم كيف كان يعني لو هو موجود اليوم
ايش كان بيقول تخيلوا لو هذا ممكن وانا
اقول لكم ممكن صار في عندنا مواقع هذا
اتني م سورت يعني ببساطه يوعدك بالخلود تش
تعيش للابد في في موقع ثاني يقوللك اسمه
اون ايش يوعدك هار
بيت ايشيب تويت عندما يتوقف نبض قلبك
ستستمرين في التغريد ايه ده يعني ايش اللي
حاصل معناته انكم بعد ما تموتوا بيجي جهاز
معين يعني ذكاء اصطناعي ويتقمص شخصيتكم
بيكون فلان او فلانه رساله الجمعه اللي
ترسلوها قران جمعه مباركه مصحف ولا ورود
يرسلها عنكم ايش كمان تعملوا حاجه انتم
متعودين عليها وربما لو كان يعني الزمن
شويه رجع لوراء كان ممكن ابراهيم رد علينا
الله
يرحمه في 2014 جوني ديب بتقولوا ايش قصتك
انت وهوليوود
افلام ايش نعمل جوني ديب عمل فيلم اسمه
ترانسيندنس اللي هو التجاوز يحكي قصه عالم
مات
وقل مخه او يعني عقله على الانترنت خ
[تصفيق]
نشوف all over the country we decades of
research and
dev
bu
اخر حاجه يجي الكمبيوتر ويقول هل هناك من
احد تعرفوا القصص اللي يقول الكمبيوترات
بتغز الارض وبتكون تمشي الانسان على فها
هذا الفيلم انا اعتقد ان السينما هي تحاكي
الواقع او تستبق يعني ستار ورز او حروب
النجوم قبل فتره كانوا ماسكين موبايلات
غريبه وكانوا يمسك السكرين ويعمل عليها
والان قد موجوده
فربما السينما اللي تقوله في 2014 انه
يكون حقيقي بعد مش عارفه كم الموضوع انه
الانترنت صار شيء مهول تكنولوجيا الاتصال
يعني واقع امامكم وانا اوعدكم ان 2014 هي
اللي نسميها سيتي مومنت او سنه نوعيه او
لحظه نوعيه الان انتم عايشين في لحظه
تاريخيه نوعيه يعني ستسجل للتاريخ الطريقه
اللي انتم بتتعاملوا فيها في الامور
بتتغير موازين الامور كلها بتتغير ماد فيش
حكايه انه انا اتراسل مع شخص بطريقه معينه
او انا انتظر من جريده او موقع انه يكلمني
بطريقه معينه هذا الشيء كله انتهى
الاعلاميين بالذات اللي عادهم متقوقعين في
اطار الاعلام التقليدي اللي هو لا انا
بحتك المعلومه المتلقي بينتظر مني لا
المتلقي ما بينتظر وما بيستني الخبر
الاذاعي او الخبر التلفزيوني عنده عنده
مليون طريقه وذلك الاعلام بينتهي المستقبل
ما بيكونش في حاجه اسمها اعلام بون في
حاجه اسمها اتصال والاتصال هذا بيكون تو
واي يعني بيكون يعني انتراكت مش بالطريقه
اللي في موقع الكتروني اعمل كومنت او
تعليق وانتظر انه هو مدير الموقع يوافق
على التق لا لا يعني تفاعل رهيب اني ومفصل
على قياسكم بالضبط هذه هي السنه اللي هي
السنيتي ير وتاكدوا ان اي حاجه تحطوها على
الانترنت انها بترجع لكم ترجع لكم بعد ما
تموتوا ترجع لكم لما يشتي واحد يشتي يتقدم
لعروسه ويرجعوا يشوفوا ايش كان يكتب
بالفيسبوك
ولا بنتك بتكبر وتشوف ماما ايش كانت
تقول فاي ح ترموها على الانترنت حتى لو
عملتم ديليت تاكدوا انها قد راحت وحفظت
ترجع لكم ويوم من الايام يعني بتندموا او
بتفرحوا على الطريقه اللي انتم تصرفت بها
تجاه تكنولوجيا الاتصال
[تصفيق]
شكرا